wyoming's always been a state that
emphasizes rugged individualism
we're pretty libertarian always have
been the golden hills of wyoming an
ever-spinning wheel of fortune that
caught in its mad world adventurers
pioneers the renegade [ __ ]
however throughout wyoming's history
commodities not rugged individualism has
powered its economy
the commodity that we got established on
was cattle and the commodity that came
into our future fairly shortly
thereafter was oil
and then came cold
we're struggling right now to transition
with that history because we rely
heavily on coal oil and gas for most of
our state's revenue
there has been a long term discussion
about diversifying our economy we've
recognized that depletable resources
we've banked on coal and oil and gas are
eventually going to be depleted
today wyoming is looking to embrace a
new commodity we need to find
alternative industries and viable
sectors both blockchain and
cryptocurrency
represent values that wyoming can get
online with
as the world of blockchain and crypto
goes more and more mainstream the race
for the state to be crowned the most
crypto friendly is on
when you think of crypto friendly cities
you have to start with miami florida the
miami mayor francis soros i want us to
differentiate ourselves as a crypto
capital of the united states or of the
world new york city mayor eric adams new
york city is going to be the center of
the cryptocurrency industry
but that race is led by the cowboy state
it's about philosophy on this one and
it's the philosophy of that rugged
individualism the independence and the
ability to really get things done for
yourself and control your own destiny
you get that from a blockchain and you
don't get that without it
[Music]
my name is caitlin long i'm co-founder
avanti financial group which is a bank
chartered to serve the digital asset
industry in wyoming that will be
operating in 2022.
caitlyn long was born in wyoming but
spent the majority of her career working
for morgan stanley in new york however
she's always kept one foot back home in
cheyenne
wyoming has a really interesting history
of leading
wyoming gave women the right to vote 50
years before the rest of the united
states
when wyoming invented the limited
liability company new form of business
entity in 1977
it took about a decade for the rest of
the united states to follow wyoming here
wyoming is leading yet again in digital
asset laws we already are seeing other
states follow i think it won't even take
a decade for the critical laws of
wyoming to be enacted by the other
states in the united states
because of champions like caitlyn long
wyoming is leading the charge when it
comes to integrating blockchain and
crypto to u.s law
when i got into bitcoin um got some
early coins decided when it started
running up in the previous bull market
in 2017 to donate some appreciated
bitcoin to the university of wyoming
foundation to fund scholarships for
female engineers
and i thought well i'll just quietly use
some of my bitcoin gains to help solve
that problem
and the university of wyoming just sort
of shrugged their shoulders and probably
said something along the lines of what's
bitcoin
the university of wyoming could not
accept her donation because the state's
money transfer laws restrict certain
kinds of assets
i said at the time we've got to fix this
because this bitcoin thing is going to
be big and you don't want to miss it we
thought well what are we doing that for
that's ridiculous so in 2016 we started
to look at this money transmitter act
revision
what started as an attempt to give back
to her home state ended with her leading
the charge on wyoming's cryptocurrency
and blockchain regulations
we really started to realize that
there was an open landscape for
developing policy around blockchain and
digital assets
we got together at that point and we
kind of formed this little collaborative
team of enthusiasts and policy makers
that started planning for what a future
could look like with digital assets
there were 90 people involved at the
legislature and about 30 people who
endorsed this outside of the legislature
in the very beginning
since that time we put together the
blockchain task force and now we
formalized it into a permanent select
committee
after fixing the money transmitter
statute the task force took on a whole
host of other laws concerning blockchain
and crypto
there have been 24 laws passed in four
different legislative sessions but i'd
say the most important ones are that
wyoming clarified the legal status of
digital assets
we realized there was an open question
about what is a digital asset what is a
cryptocurrency when it comes to property
rights and statutes if a court is
looking at this asset what are they
going to do with it
we defined it as property and that's the
basis upon which financial services can
be built and just basically making the
law compatible with the way the
technology was actually working very
foundational
the next steps to fundamentally change
the banking system in wyoming and
possibly the country
we have something called a dual banking
system in the united states where some
banks are chartered federally and some
banks are chartered by the states but if
an organization dealt with crypto they
were not allowed to use the us banking
system
if you had crypto if you had blockchain
if you had any word associated with it
in your name or your business model or
your business plan you wouldn't get
banked and if you can't get banked you
can't have a business so we created a
whole new type of state chartered bank
called the special purpose depository
institution the speedy bank
it operates the core payment systems for
the u.s dollar specifically ach and
fedwire
and right now there are no crypto
companies that have direct access to
that it's kept separate so banks can
access that but they can't provide
services for crypto it's a way to plug
the digital asset industry into the
traditional financial services industry
in a safe and sound manner
importantly this would also give those
crypto banks if they were to get this
speedy access to the fed's payment
system and that's really important
because that would really cut down on
the cost and the time that it takes for
these transactions to go through
if you go back to thinking about when
you were kids and you were exchanging
baseball cards with your friend what did
you do you both held on to both baseball
cards and you both let go at the same
time and then you had simultaneous
settlement of that trade of the baseball
card nobody
owed a baseball card to anybody because
the transaction happened simultaneously
the adults screwed that up
and we should learn from the kids
because the kids had it right there's no
reason why you should ever
have an iou for the baseball card
there's no reason why you should ever
have an iou for a dollar payment
we have the technology to be able to do
simultaneous settlement of a u.s dollar
against other types of assets namely
digital assets and others but we don't
have the capability
to do that because of the regulatory
regime
when i signed it i was very excited
because no one else had really done that
everybody else was trying to figure out
how to shoehorn digital asset custody
into an existing trust structure or into
some sort of existing banking structure
regrettably
we see at the national level that
there's a tremendous amount of
resistance crypto markets aren't
actually an alternative to our banking
system they're a mirror of the same
broken system with even less
accountability and no rules at all if
you were buying stock for speculation
you'd be protected by rules against
things like pump and dump
but
not when you're buying bitcoin for
speculation
there are four chartered wyoming
speedies and none of us have been
approved by the federal reserve yet
one of
cryptocurrency's biggest hurdles really
is that it is so new the fact that you
know it is such a turbulent asset can
kind of spook some of traditional wall
street and professional money managers i
do think they are risky they're not
backed by anything the reason they see
resistance is because we're creating a
banking institution that doesn't require
fdic insurance the reason it doesn't
require fdinc insurance is because it's
not able to be at risk it's a 100
percent
reserve 100 depository institution
that's incapable of lending out
those funds
i've been back to washington two or
three times i've been told that we're
getting very close
i think that governors and bank
presidents understand how important it
is that the united states not just
wyoming but the united states actually
jump ahead on this because we are losing
ground to china if we don't get in the
game soon we are going to be playing
catch up
wyoming's crypto industry has some
allies in washington its most famous
maybe one of the state's own senators i
encourage people to buy and hold i
encourage them to say bitcoin for their
retirement for their future it's not the
wyoming way to sit around and wait for
change we want to be innovative and
we're going to push back as hard as we
can against the feds
it's not just cryptocurrencies wyoming
has taken the first step towards
recognizing companies organizations and
even cities run entirely on the
blockchain
july 1st
wyoming became the first state to
formally legally recognize the
centralized autonomous organizations or
daos
in our statutes and we created the dow
llc it's a fancy way of saying you can
establish a company using blockchain and
put it under an llc moniker
wyoming really has been a leader in
business activity
for
decades llcs were first established in
wyoming law and this is just an
extension of that llc we're kind of
going back to the original roots of how
do you let people self-organize and give
them
the ability to do a couple of things the
idea of a dao is the idea that we're
going to have some portion of our
company's responsibilities delegated to
algorithms
programming code where code is going to
run the company as opposed to your
manager or members that that show up
every day to the office we're just gonna
turn it over to code
one of the biggest doubts out there that
people know the most about is a group
that's known as constitution dao
they crowdsourced a bunch of funding to
try to buy the u.s constitution at
sotheby's they actually raised over 40
million in less than two weeks we would
really love to display that constitution
at the university of wyoming and so even
the governor of wyoming got involved
to try to basically market to the 15 000
people each of whom had a vote on where
the constitution if constitution dao had
won where was that constitution going to
be displayed begin the auction lot 1787
the constitution of the united states of
america united states constitution at 41
million dollars sold 41. they of course
lost to citadel chief executive officer
ken griffin but it really was sort of
the proof of concept for a lot of people
when it came to daos
we've already had over 150 dows filed in
the state of wyoming
the billionaire zombies club is an nft
art collective which is transitioning to
dow leadership alicia is a korea based
dab project that finances real estate
with crypto
you have crypto tokens like elo coin
space dogs and even a collective that
plays blockchain based games together
there are companies from all over the
world that are now looking at wyoming as
a place where they want to innovate and
create new
products or
technologies or businesses that are
formed through a dow llc
and within wyoming's own borders is one
of the most ambitious dows yet city
dao's citizens took advantage of
wyoming's new laws by collectively
purchasing 40 acres near the montana
wyoming border about 6 hours from
cheyenne
basic citizenship with voting rights is
about 3 dollars and each subplot of land
goes for three hundred dollars
city hall is located on a discord where
members share memes lofty goals and
details of a recent hack
if you do any kind of business in this
country there's a pretty good chance
that you're going to see that business
registered in delaware why because
that's where you do it and our point was
wyoming can be that venue for blockchain
enterprise for crypto
we're seeing businesses from around the
country
locate
mining operations and in fact we just
had one that moved its headquarters to
wyoming
one of those businesses is elite mining
elite mining is a green mining company
that mines bitcoin and other algorithms
on the blockchain thank you everyone for
coming i cannot begin to tell you how
humbling a moment this is for me
elite mining is one of the first
companies that's actually shifted
operations into cheyenne
our company itself uses payroll through
blockchains
all of our employees team members
contractors we pay them all through
cryptocurrency the whole city as a whole
has welcomed us with open arms rolled
out the red carpet for us and
essentially said we want to work with
you
i fit right in because i'm from a small
town personally and uh and this is more
of a small town that's growing into what
i would call the cryptocurrency version
of silicon valley
we want to make sure that people
understand especially in wyoming but as
you know united states as a whole
that this this trend is coming it's not
going to stop
when we get to the point where we've
completely implemented this blockchain
technology when we have digital
identities that allow us to engage
authoritatively with our banks and with
our government
we can have privacy rights that we want
not that are either allowed to us or
forced upon us
we want that independence we want that
freedom we want that individuality
and that's a common theme that brings
together honestly a bipartisan support
for this in wyoming
you